Dr. Cutter's recommended adding liposomal gluteiclear to my
protocol after my DNA test results came in. I am an avoidant glutathione after reading
how to start your cancer by Jade McClellan and after reading naturopathic oncology by Dr. McKinney.
It was said to avoid glutathione because it's a strong antioxidant that may encourage cancer growth.
Intruths not to toot my own horde, but I think both those people got that information from my
book, Southbyte Cancer, because I was, I believe, one of the first people that said that you
should avoid glutathione with cancer. Now I have a sense, reverse that standpoint. So I don't think
it's wrong to support your body with antioxidants. So I I've reversed that through different
research that's come out, other things that I've been reading, and you know, you could disagree
with me. That's fine. And other doctors could disagree with me. That's fine, but my stance is
that I'm just going to constantly be trying to learn and grow and and not take a dogmatic position
at anything. So if I learned something new, I'm going to change what I thought was right. And now I
know better. Maybe I'm wrong on this too. So I don't know, but I think now it's it's good to support
that especially if you have. And I don't recommend like a glutathione. It's just haphazardly like to
somebody, everybody should be able to go to that. I don't think that when you have very serious
defects on your glutathione pathways, if you're glutathione recycling pathways, that is
probably one of the reasons why you got cancer. Because if you can't get rid of poisons,
that's what glutathione does. It gets rid of oxidized, it gets rid of oxidizing agents.
So oxidizing agents are going to damage your your cells and are the leading cause of cancer.
So the damage to your glutathione genes, you're going to have less glutathione, less support in
your antioxidant pathways, less intercellular antioxidation, and more damage to the oxidizing agents
like pesticides, chemicals, micro tungsten, so heavy metals, all these different things that
are causes of cancer. So that's what's going to happen.